ils sont architectes urbanistes ou
encore auteur des disciplines
différentes pour un univers commun le
paysage pendant plusieurs mois les
lauréats de la villa le nôtre vont
développer leur projet ce que j'ai
choisi c'est c'est de penser ce cette
ville forêt comme un concept d'ouverture
des champs et l'idée de partir d'une
enquête pour proposer une réécriture
cartographique de la vie forêt sur le
site de versailles donc l'idée c'est
plutôt de questionner nos rapports à la
forêt historiquement et c'est pour
rendre hommage à ce lieu magnifique et
tous les animaux les insectes et les
plantes qui met en fait aussi parce que
comme common life qui sait ont toutes
les deux on a dans des genres très fin
dans des gens différents on a pas mal
travaillé sur les jardins
pour cette troisième édition le jury a
reçu 26 dossiers de candidature dont 16
internationale les lauréats feront des
résidences de 3 à 6 mois proposée par la
villa le nôtre un accueil au coeur de
l'école nationale supérieure du paysage
de versailles
la logique c'est de bien renouer avec ce
que porte de versailles
c'est à dire une ville ouverte sur le
monde une ville qui s'est inspiré de des
mouvements et des dépenses et
internationales mais aussi qui a rayonné
et donc d'être dense est dans cette
dynamique là les résidences prendront
fin au mois de mai 2019
les productions iront du livre augmenté
au manuscrit en passant par la création
d'un atlas cartographique